Let's stick on the Islamic dilemma. But
answer my question, dude. Please. Does
you just said the Quranic author assumes
and thinks and believes that the Torah
and the Gospel are inspired,
authoritative, and preserved. Would I be
correct in saying that?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah, I think so. Yeah.
>> See,
>> beautiful.
>> They've been saying that from the
beginning.
>> That means he must think that it's
absolutely confirmed and true, right?
Okay, if you want to go with that.
>> Okay, so now you backtrack. Thank you.
>> Yes, he thought everything in those
scriptures are completely authentic and
true. No errors.
And I'm I'll prove it. I wish Dean come.
I'm going to give you Quranic ayat and
I'm going to use your 482 example and
your
am. I'll use it against you, brother.
Dean, I know you're listening. Come up,
man.
So yeah, it [laughter]
disagreed with you.
>> It is. Yeah, because earlier you said it
doesn't hinge. Now it does hinge. You
see you see how inconsistent you are. It
does
>> Oh my god. So it does hinge on it being
absolutely true. Right.
>> Okay. Let let me express my actual
argument which for some reason you you
haven't wanted me to do so far. You I
don't think it matters whether or not
it's a absolute confirmation or a
general confirmation. I think
>> he's granting their argument. But you
heard what he said his position is,
right? And Mike said the same thing.
Moheim and Mike. They said, "We believe
that the author of the Quran meant to
confirm everything in those scriptures,
but because he's ignorant and doesn't
know any better, the narrations he gave
about biblical characters contradict the
scriptures that he thought he was
confirming in total.
But we'll even grant your general
confirmation.
I think either one proves the Islamic
dilemma. That's that's my point.
>> Okay. Okay. Beautiful. Beautiful. Let's
go with that. So with the latter that it
doesn't have to absolutely confirm, how
would the Islamist dilemma then follow?
>> The Islamic dilemma would follow because
under a general confirmation, the major
themes and narratives of the Torah and
the Gospels are still being confirmed.
Those would be things such
>> understand what he's saying. Even if the
Quran doesn't confirm every detail,
minutia of every
story. The Quran is confirming
the doctrines of those scriptures.
Otherwise, how do you know that Muhammad
is a prophet in conformity with the
prophets
that were given those scriptures? You
understand what he's saying here? So,
that means the Quran is confirming their
understanding of God, right? their
understanding of
salvation, their understanding of sin,
righteousness, holiness, their
understanding of the afterlife,
day of resurre. You understand what he's
saying? And that the Quran would also
have to confirm the prophetic
understanding of the Messiah.
You get the point, right?
>> Such as the incarnation, the
crucifixion, the resurrection, the
baptism, the views on the afterlife. You
you could go through tons of these
things and not a single one of these
things, these major narratives works
with the Quran and hence
>> the Quran the Quran the one second. The
Quran confirms the hypothatic union.
>> Now we're going to go into meat. The
Quran confirms hypothatic union. Yep.
Come prove me wrong. I'm going to use
Luke right now for your janaza coward.
>> Does the Quran confirm John's prologue?
>> No.
>> But okay. Why why doesn't it?
>> Watch here. Watch the barrier. Because
the Quran doesn't have a middle platonic
view like John's prolog does.
>> I'm now going to prove his prophet was a
middle platonist. Get ready. We're now
going to have fun. [laughter]
Shish kebab at Allah's expense.
>> Okay. And you know this how exactly?
>> We know this because the contemporary of
John Pho of Alexandria who writes um
>> wait why why are you going to ask
>> you just asked me how I know. He didn't
ask you how you know that the Quran
doesn't confirm John's middle platonic
understanding of the logos. How do you
know that the Quran is not confirming
what John says about the word? So he's
saying, well, I know that John is
talking about middle platonic notions of
the logos because Pho and Alex al
Alexandrian Jew use middle platonism to
describe the logos to the Greeks to show
that Judaism is compatible with the
notion of the logos. But Pho believed
that the logos doctrine is anchored in
derived from the Old Testament as
evidence also with the Aramaic
paraphrases of the Old Testament called
the Targum.
Just because they'll use philosophical
categories to explain what's already in
their scriptures to pagans like your
prophet Muhammad to show them that this
notion of logos already affirmed
articulated by the true God and his true
scriptures. So come home. If Muhammad is
confirming the scriptures
of the Jews and Christians and those
scriptures contain John, then he's
confirming John's logos Christology,
which means you just submit Muhammad as
a middle platonist. And I'll get there.
I'll get there. Just let him bark some
more so I can simmer as Lark on the
black stone.
>> 471
makes it absolutely clear. It describes
Jesus as the word. This term is the word
confirming John 1:1. So the concept of
Jes the concept of Jesus being the word
of God is confirmed in Luke not in John
because Luke
>> presents Jesus as being the word Stop.
Why are you interrupting dude?
>> Oh no
>> Lotus the victim narcissist. Muhammad
was the master narcissist. You see
narcissism. You have a picture Muhammad
and the black stone. You keep cutting
them off and now you're playing the
victim.
>> Sorry I do. I get that when I get
excited. Yeah, I know. I know you're so
excited right now to get baked.
>> So, the word of God motif, the word of
God,
>> bro, be quiet.
>> I I think he's still getting excited.
>> I know. The word of God motif. The word
of God motif in the Quran
>> is a Jewish word of God motif that's
found in Luke's narrative, not in John's
narrative. John's narrative is a middle
platonic idea of the logos of God.
However, when we go to Luke's narrative,
we see that the word of God there is
similar to what the Quran sees Jesus as
being the word of God. Because Luke
speaks of Jesus as the word being
fulfilled to Mary. That's why Mary says,
"May your word be fulfilled to me." So
when the angel comes to Mary, he gives
her a word. And Mary says, "May that
word be fulfilled."
>> Watch what I'm going to do. Keep in
mind, oh boy, Janza is going to be
beautiful. Dean, I know you're watching.
Dean, come here. Bail out your porker
because he's too scared to show up
>> to me. And that is exactly why, let me
finish. That is exactly why the Quran
interext with Luke's uh um uh birth
narrative in chapter Mary. You have John
the Baptist and Jesus, John the Baptist
birth, Jesus's birth, and you have that
being contrasted with Luke. So now I
don't have to
>> I know I'm landing. I promise
>> I don't have to concede
>> that the word of God motif comes from
John.
>> The word of God motif comes from Luke.
>> Okay. So
>> guys, remember the 25 minute 52 mark.
Now we're going to go into meat. And by
the way, Albi is talking to Teen
Response. So Dean is watching. He says,
"If you come up, Albby and moderate."
Dean, don't be scared.
You speak respectfully. I'm not going to
insult you. If you conduct yourself the
way you did on this channel, I ain't
going to insult you. But I'm not going
to let you spin and ask the same
question for five hours. And I'm going
to nail you because we're going to go to
the text, and I'm going to use your
arguments against you. So come on. Don't
be scared. All right. Now, watch, guys.
You ready?
Watch.
Please remind me of the 25 minute 50cond
mark. He said Luke, right? [laughter]
Oh, watch the janaza. He said Luke,
right? Because why? In Luke, John's
birth is narrated as well as Jesus. And
the Quran juxtaposes the birth of John
with Jesus in. But it's also IN
[screaming]
remember he said Luke right now. Now,
let's see if he's going to backtrack and
he's going to try to, you know, do some
backstrokes.
Thank you, pagans. Don't licker
cuz I'm now going to do janaz on you.
All right, let's hear
Luke. He said he's referring to Luke 1
38. Let's see if it's large enough. Let
me just go a little lower. It's the
Okay, Luke 1:38. He goes, "The word that
Gabriel gave to her, right?" All right.
[snorts] And Mary said, "Behold the
slave of the Lord, may it be done to me
according to your word." And the angel
departed from her. Now, let's read.
It may take me an hour just to unpack
this. So, bear with me. I will do a part
two. Now, in the sixth month, the angel
Gabriel was sent from God to a city in
Galilee called Nazareth. Nazareth to a
virgin betrod to a man whose name was
Joseph of the house of David. And the
virgin's name was Mary. And coming in,
he said to her, "Greetings," at this
statement, "I'm sorry." Greetings, favor
one. The Lord is with you. But she was
very perplexed at this statement, and
was pondering what kind of greeting this
was. And the angel said to her, "Do not
be afraid, Mary, for you have found
favor with God. Behold, you will
conceive in your womb and bear a son.
You shall call him that shall name him
Jesus. He will be great and will be
called the son of the most high." Damn,
Gina.
Remember what Porky Pig said? Sheck
Porky. The Quran is confirming
Luke's Jewish
conception of Jesus being the word. The
Quran is confirming that this is the
word that Gabriel gave to Mary.
Remember he said it.
Okay, watch. Watch how bad it's going to
get.
Not only is he the son of the most high,
you're right there. You just buried the
Quran and showed Muhammad as an
antichrist
and he'll reign over the house of Jacob
forever and there will be no end of his
kingdom. He just said the Quran
confirmed this word about Jesus. So he
just admitted to you that the Quran
confirmed Jesus is the eternal king
whose kingdom will never end. See what
he just did? Oh, watch the shesh kebab.
I'm so excited that Muhammad is being
exposed and he's being more for
producing such pagans. Thank you, Lord
Jesus Almighty.
Give me the power and the health and the
holiness to delight your heart and bless
me to see my daughters become godly
women. Okay, watch here. Oh, it's going
to get worse. So, wait. Does Orthodox
Come on up. I'm going to ask you the
question. Do you now believe Jesus is an
eternal king whose kingdom is
indestructible?
Oh yeah, but he's the king of Israel. He
only rules over Israel. No, jackass. I'm
going to show you that to be the king of
Israel makes you the king of the world
according to both the Old Testament and
New Testament and Luke.
Come on up, Dean responds. Save your
dude. Save him from the Shia broth. Dean
respond, I know you're listening. Come
destroy my career.
come. You just said, and I'm going to
show you something shocking from the
Quran that confirms what we're about to
read.
Okay. So, and but Mary said to the
angel, "How will this be since I'm a
virgin?" The angel answered and said to
her, "The Holy Spirit will come upon
you, and the power of the most high will
overshadow you, and for that reason, the
holy child shall be called the SON OF
GOD." DAMN, GINA, he just told you this
is what the Quran confirmed.
So according to Orthodox, the QR
confirms Jesus is the son of God, the
son of the most high who will reign over
David's throne forever and ever. So he's
an eternal king. He just admitted. And
behold, your relative Elizabeth has also
conceived a son in her old age. And this
is the sixth month for her who was
called barren. For nothing will be
impossible with God. And this is the
context. And Mary be said, "Behold the
slave of the Lord. May it be done to me
according to your word. Be done to me
what? That I conceive by the spirit as a
virgin the holy son of God who is a king
whose kingdom cannot be destroyed." I
mean, Orthodox, when are you going to
get baptized, Miss Piggy?
But it gets worse, guys. And the angel
from Watch how bad it gets,
man. Watch here. What about John? Let's
watch this about John. For he will be
great talking about John in the sight of
the Lord. He will not drink any wine or
strong drink. He'll be filled with the
Holy Spirit while yet in his mother's
womb. Now watch. While in his mother's
womb is filled with the Holy Spirit. Now
watch. Remember he said this is what the
Quran is confirming. And he thought he's
going to make it easier for a sake guys.
Watch here. Now at this time Mary Rose
went in hurry to the hill country to a
city of Judah and entered the house of
Zacharia and greeted Elizabeth and it
happened that when Elizabeth heard
Mary's greeting the baby leaped in her
womb and Elizabeth's filled with the
Holy Spirit two things
John is six months old in the womb.
Point number two, he is filled with the
Holy Spirit and his mother's filled with
the Holy Spirit while
he is in his mother's womb. When Mary
walks in, he leaps in his womb.
Why? And she cried out with a loud
voice, "Blessed are you among women.
Blessed is fruit of your womb. And how
has it happened to me that the mother of
my Lord would come to me? Damn, Gina.
[laughter]
[screaming]
[sighs]
Elizabeth being filled with the spirit
and John filled the spirit is moved with
ecstasy confessing Mary is the mother my
lord. So the child she just conceived is
the Lord of John and Elizabeth. And you
just said the Quran confirms this. I'm
going to show you how this buries the
Quran.
Watch how it's going to bury the Quran.
So what was John the Baptist's reaction?
For behold, when the sound of your
greeting reached my ears, the baby
leaped in my womb for joy. Why did John
leap? When he heard the sound of Mary
who had just conceived his Lord in her
womb. The Holy Spirit filled John and
made John aware. That's the mother of
your Lord. Rejoice.
And blessed is she who believed that
there would be a fulfillment of what had
been spoken to her by the Lord. Now
watch this. John and Elizabeth are
elated, filled with joy at the presence
of Mary because she had now conceived
Jesus. And Elizabeth by the spirit
recognizes that child is my Lord. Damn,
Gina.
We're going to have a nice shish kebab
today. Shake and Beck, baby. Shake it
and make it. Shake it, man. Oh man, why
so like this man? See why the cowards
won't show up? You just showed that by
the Quran confirming Luke, the Islamic
dilemma is true because Luke buries your
prophet. You just confirm the Islamic
dilemma.
3790.
[clears throat]
It is not possible that a man to whom is
given the book and wisdom and the
prophetic office should say to people,
now literally it says, "Be you my
servant, serve me, I which they take to
be worshiped." That's fine. But watch
here.
It is not possible for any human being
unto whom Allah had given the scripture
and wisdom the prophet that he should
afterwards have said unto mankind, "Be
slaves of me instead of Allah."
Right? Be slaves of me instead of Allah.
But what he said was, "Be ye faithful
servants of the Lord by virtue of your
constant teaching of scripture and of
your constant study thereof." Now watch.
And he commanded you not that you should
take the angels and prophets for lords.
Would he command you to believe after
you had surrendered to Allah? Now you
see he just confirmed that the Quran
confirmed Luke that this is what it
means for Jesus be the word. But in
saying that the Quran confirms Luke, you
just proved the Islamic dilemma of the
Quran is a lie. Because the part in Luke
that you quoted, Stone Licker, Jesus is
the son of God, an eternal king, and
Elizabeth recognizes him as her Lord,
my Lord.
You see the Islamic dilemma.